ich muss dir spielsucht jede menge
schulden abbezahlen deswegen muss ich ja
charaktertyp auf jeden fall ist immer
eine gute strategie wenn man
familienvater ist als körper zu arbeiten
hast du alle lampen im zorn meinten
damit er die zeit ist reif der tag ist
gekommen um sich wieder einmal mit
unserer lieblings rtl2-sendung
auseinanderzusetzen wenn es vor einigen
tagen eine folge angekommen die allein
schon vom titel her einem wieder den
anlass gibt mit schwung den kopf in eine
kreissäge zu halten und so schafft es
heute die folge tagsüber vater nachts
über call boy ich verkaufe meinen körper
an scheiße und leute es ist mir eine
riesengroße freude zur heutigen folge
einen besonderen gast auf diesem kanal
begrüßen zu dürfen applaus für den job
ein urgestein ein ganz kurzer blick in
die besteuerung auf und bat uns den
inhalt dieser höchst unsinnigen folge
und zwar wie folgt nachdem dominik 24
wegen seiner spielschulden komplett
abgestürzt ist und privatinsolvenz
anmelden musste ist er mit ehefrau pia
und dem gemeinsamen sohn louis und einen
kleinen wohnbau angezogen und kämpfen
ums überleben mit seinem lausige zeiten
barkeeper job keine die familie kaum
darüber was in seiner geld bekommt er
über seinen chef michael in der basis
angebot als callboy für gut betuchten
damen zu arbeiten
ganz kurze heftige schockmoment mit dem
schreiben könnt mir schon fast glauben
das ist tatsächlich mal eine folge ist
in der so jemand geht der jung pleite
und verzweifelt es okay
[Musik]
was ist das schon wieder für ein grenz
behinderter anfang von einer folge alter
warum es in die ersten sieg und immer so
abstoßen soll
es ist quasi das gleiche leute man
bekommt auch gar keinen fall hier
irgendwie leicht einschicken diese
folgen das wird einem ins gesicht
gehämmert vorschlaghammer dass das alter
einfach so eine leicht bekleidete etwas
ältere frau und ein typ in strapsen ich
habe jetzt schon keinen bock mehr
ja da hast du mal sagen heutzutage ist
wird mir sicher könnt ihr mit gewissheit
sagen dass euer vater nicht nachts als
callboy arbeitet wer kann das schon
sagen niemand ist mehr sicher leute
diese probleme die in dieser folge
beschrieben werden sind wie immer
probleme die in der gesellschaft weit
verbreitet sind und dementsprechend
solltet ihr vielleicht fragt aber federn
ich hab die kinos sondern fragt mal
100.000
machst du hast du sie bitte der bahre
und erhält so viele leute an so aber war
das seltsame ist erster probleme sind
träger anfangen aber nichts mehr sonst
am oberkörper so das ist kein ort wurde
unscheinbar sein muss hat er wenn du da
rein läuft oder stalking drei arme würde
es kaum auffallen wird undercover
ich muss so ein scheißdreck wie will er
bitte an der kamera mit dieser situation
ganz kurz was in der bar wo der
barkeeper einfach nur hosenträger
workbench einen ball war aber er will
hat in den korb bei war nicht als
callboy bei der erscheinung treten
ja ja ja und sie kommen nicht so gut mit
zurückweisung zurecht gekommen
jetzt soll er sagen als eine tagung ist
einfach aufgeflogen ist eine vollkommen
normale lokale und hat wirklich intensiv
versucht undercover zu bleiben es ist
leider gescheitert
da wird sowieso wieder balima kopf
drückt er den spruch was ist was so los
ist damit bekomme ich kann das nicht
meine frau er ist colruyt aber darf
niemand mitbekommen aber es ist ein
arbeitsplatz wo er kurz darauf scheinbar
niemand mitbekommen weil er der typ
hinter der bar hat offensichtlich sei
aber der kommt auch einen ganz anderen
milieu natürlich der konservative
situation gesichtsausdruck ist
[Gelächter]
lukas hat sich mal den angestellt und
sie ausgezogen und trainieren dürfen
ganz kurz heute das leben schon einige
leute die wissen was geld ist geld ist
seit so gut erklärt den anderen
zuschauer in den kommentaren mal was es
mit geldes geld von der baywa auf sich
hat für die frau tun die aufs spiel
setzt
ich musste ihm oder spielsucht jede
menge schulden abbezahlt deswegen muss
ich deswegen muss ich mir was du gesagt
muss ich dann werden deswegen musste ich
geboren wurde oder spielsucht jede menge
schulden abbezahlen
deswegen muss ich kann gebissen das
reicht nicht für das essen und trinken
und meinen job in der bar der bringt nun
mal nicht genug ein qualitativ auf jeden
fall ist immer eine gute strategie wenn
man familienvater ist familienvater
alter als körper zu arbeiten einer art
noch alle lampen im zaun wohnen holz
konnte
jugendritter das hätten die selbst
[Musik]
ich musste länger machen was sie zu tun
ich muss doch ich musste während die
mutter sei hier guck mal da ist er kult
die mutter sagt papa ist wieder da er
gerade ein geschenk versorgt schon
geburtstag wird man nicht ganz
verstanden diesen job funktioniert wie
du kriegst geld von seinem chef
wie geht das ergibt die einfach so geld
übergeht unseren checken
[Musik]
ich gehe das nicht nur für unsere
gläubiger arbeiten oder besser gesagt
spielt das kind auf eine decke von der
merkur spielothek
er ist das logo eines bedingt dieter
bartmann er spielschulden die jungen der
ist ja voll ok aber in deutschland
richtig gefeiert deshalb weniger gespürt
habe ich in den privat insolvenz
getrieben
ja also eine merkwürdige das ist genau
das richtige für mein kind und das kind
denkt sich so papa was bis dahin spaß
ganz nicht einmal bei einer partie die
bandbreiten ich will meinem sohn
nächstens zum geburtstag bieten und ohne
drin sein oder nicht ja aber trotzdem
daran kann er sich doch gar nicht mehr
dran erinnern
aber man muss sagen also das set ist
wieder seltsam das sieht aus wie so ein
garten auch schritte dahin zu setzen für
riesen irgendwie
bis zu drei meter 80 die kopfstütze dazu
kommen wahrscheinlich das günstigste
airbnb in köln genommen wieder als echte
herzlichkeit box und erwin diese für 80
euro bezahlt aber das ist wieder so ein
garten haus gemietet hatte jetzt war er
wieder mal mit dem production value am
start ich habe mir noch geld geborgt von
man chef
das muss ja auch zurückzahlen ja trotz
allem krimi was ist ihre einschätzung zu
diesem jungen familienvater der vater
versucht einen verkompliziert sich
schneebretter den oft über ihr leid
dichter geld vom chef und zahlt die
schulden von anderen chef harry geld von
privatair irgendeiner art wenig leuten
kann
meinst du ich hab da muss zu überstunden
zu schieben und so dann muss ich mich
jetzt noch rechtfertigen
unter aller sau
der mann kommt müde nach hause und will
sich dann hinlegen aber er war ja
nirgendwo offiziell denn einfach nur so
die nacht durchgearbeitet in besserem
beschließt um zwei wahrscheinlich kommen
so dzeko morgens nach hause
ja ja wieder los in davos
ganz kurz was was was für ein job hat
der typ kommt es in zehn sekunden zu
hause muss daher muss laut wurde es ist
ja schon unter normalen umständen für
ein junges paar mit kind nicht leicht
diese ganzen herausforderungen
aufzufangen
zum einen die finanzielle situation der
schuh drückt an allen ecken und enden ja
der schuh drückt ein engel enten ganz
kurz zu dem thema warum hat die schuhe
zu hause also einen keiner ran kommen da
sie hat einfach wie so ist und wie soll
sonst klappt das ja ein
[Gelächter]
damit lag man entdecken kann
da musst du jetzt darum ja weil du mich
jetzt wieder alleine lässt und ich
wiederum alles alleine kümmern kann und
meine ich meiner mutter wieder
rechenschaft schuldig bin warum du
wieder eine arbeit ist sie sollten wir
hier sehr zufrieden geben dass sie in
dem sparenberg im kasten sein kann
der vater tut sein bestes
das mache das potenzial bleiben ich gehe
zum geburtstag ich verstehe habe ich den
ablauf dieser szene so erzieht seine
hose
im moment sieht's verwebt wieder auflöst
warum werden auf allen infizierten dass
einer aus also die szene macht keinen
sinn weil eigentlich ist es ja so er ist
gerade bei ihr und sie will was starten
und deswegen sieht sehr gut aus aber
warum hatte er erfolglos leute wenn ihr
sehen wie es weitergeht mit dieser
wahnsinnig gewordenen frau und dem
engagierten jungen vernünftigen
familienvater dann schaltet morgen
wieder ein denn da kommt der zweite teil
ich hab euch hier drüben noch einen für
euch vorgeschlagen das video angeklickt
darauf schaut weiter und bis morgen